tu monsieur ayrault la parole est à
monsieur jacques myard allez merci s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît merci chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre de la défense et
monsieur l'homme voudrez ennemis et de
l'industrie il y a quelques semaines
j'appelle est votre attention monsieur
le ministre de la défense sur la section
des activités d'électronique de défense
d'airbus
un fonds américain kkr sic
ces activités concernent la recherche et
la réalisation des capteurs et des
équipements de guerre électronique
d'avionique et d'optronique
autant de domaines stratégiques pour
notre défense
monsieur le ministre de la défense je
vous ai demandé par question écrite si
vous entendez vous opposer à cette
session contraire à nos intérêts mais le
bradage de notre industrie continue
j'apprends que safran veut vendre sa
filiale à 100% morpho l'une des
entreprises mondiales de premier plan
pour la sécurité et la détection
d'identité morpho c'est 1 milliard 500
millions d'euros ces huit mille 600
collaborateurs vente envisagée à des
groupes anglo-saxons
rien que ça alors qu'il ya des solutions
françaises mais plus scandaleux
cette cession serait destiné à faire
monter le cours de bourse de safran avec
un gain juteux pour certains dirigeants
incroyable alors messieurs les ministres
mes questions sont simples
est ce que ce sont les personnes primées
qui détermine la stratégie de nos
intérêts industriels de défense ou le
gouvernement responsable devant le
parlement
allez vous vous opposez à ces bradage au
mépris de notre indépendance et de nos
intérêts
merci monsieur myard la palette à
monsieur le ministre un défense jean
yves le drian
monsieur le député jacques myard
merci merci de votre question que comme
vous le savez et je ne sais pas si vous
le savez morpho ne fait pas partie du
périmètre de la défense d'une part et
d'autre part n'est pas à ma connaissance
vendu il ya donc sûrement des
discussions à voir avec le groupe safran
sur ce sujet qui peuvent être partagées
par le ministre de l'économie
et croyez bien que nous y veillons avec
beaucoup d'attention en raison de
l'enjeu et sur l'autre question qu'on
m'avait posée concernant le groupe kkr
qui est le groupe qui a repris les une
partie des activités d'électronique de
défense d'airbus
l'essentiel de ses activités mais je
pense que vous le saviez
sur les 4000 emplois et l'essentiel des
activités localisés se passe en
allemagne et donc se feront l'objet
d'une autorisation des autorités
allemandes en ce qui concerne ce que je
crois est votre question principale que
je comprends sur les importations
françaises de ce groupe qui sont je
crois dans votre circonscription
donc j'y veille beaucoup je suis très
attentif croyez bien c'est ce que je
pense que c'est ça le fond de la
question croyez bien que nous y veillons
de près et que nous avons les moyens
grâce au décret iref d'assurer la
sécurité de nos intérêts nous avons reçu
les responsables et nous prendrons une
position sur ce sujet prochainement avec
la plus grande attention pour nos
intérêts de souveraineté que nous
partageons la parole